you don't need to have a soul to create
um
beautiful designs that make you feel
intense
things intense feelings we definitely
need a soul
right to look at the art and feel and
feel these things that you are feeling
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford art is no longer just for those
that can hold a paintbrush
it's quite far from that meet ben
covales the co-founder and cmo
of art ai ben is a co-founder and cmo at
art ai
a startup that develops unique
technology for producing ai generated
artworks and serves as the world's
largest
ai generated art gallery a tech startup
which is also an e-commerce and art
gallery
with the goal of democratizing art by
developing and utilizing the technology
underlying machine creativity ben's
experience as a vp
managing large international operations
that deals with e-commerce in the
financial
education sector and his fascination
with art and technology
was what drove him to co-found art ai
ben covales thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great thank you so much for
having me
thank you for taking the time to be here
ben you're the co-founder and cmo
of of an amazing startup and the reason
it's amazing is not just because
perhaps you you run it well or that or
that you know internally things are good
but because
it's it's dealing with it with something
that the world doesn't even know
how to fathom yet literally artificial
intelligence
in conjunction with creativity and how
you know the future of art will look
like
and this is coincidentally something
that i've been researching over the past
few months
at stanford in one of my classes and of
course i came across your work as well
and so i'm excited to now hear from the
primary source
and i will be using this in my research
paper so i'm wearing you ahead of time
but but ben before all that take me all
the way back to your journey and then
how do you find yourself being a
chief marketing officer of a company
that is doing ai for
art
okay so um that's a great question and
let me regard your
previous statement for a quick second we
would love to take part
in any paper or any type of project that
you're doing on this topic because one
of the main things that we are
putting a lot of energies on at the
moment is to make sure that as many
people as possible
hear about air generated art and machine
creativity
and speak about its implications on the
future of art in general
the future of the world that we know it
today and
the story about how everything started
is quite a fascinating one
so i need to go a bit back
um to 2019
or actually i need to go even before
that to october 2018
where the first ai generated artwork
was sold in an auction and it was not
the first air generated artwork that was
ever created but it was the first one
that was sold in an auction
and that happened on christie's and it
was sold
for the amazing price of 432
000 and this artwork
that's exact that's exact and so you
already
probably know how it looks like if you
know the full name
of the portrait and you can probably
also know that even though it
is amazing and as a tech savvy myself i
really like it
it is not with let's say the most
amazing
quality i think the the scientific term
for it will probably be
um blurry and bitter
or pixelated so um
rti was founded by me and two of my
friends
uh we're all childhood friends uh ayal
fisher and guy kaimovic
we all grew up together in hodocharon
and we always wanted
um like every israeli to open a startup
company together
that was the dream and we were really
fascinated with neural networks at the
past few years and we were bouncing
around ideas
that could be used as a successful
startup
uh and when this happened when we saw
this amazing event
al was the one that showed it to us and
like look this is amazing
an outlook that was created by
artificial intelligence and it was sold
for 432 000
that's amazing and we all agreed about
it uh
and danielle said that and he and he
comes with a background
um of uh image processing he was doing
his phd
in the uh genomical statistics in
cambridge at the time
uh genetics i i don't even show that
that i'm saying it correctly
it was about genetics and image
processing in the molecular level
so he knew quite a lot about image
processing and he
say he he said that he think that he can
create
ai generated art these designs but
with with much higher quality and
at a much bigger scale because there was
a very very interesting conversation
behind this artwork being sold for 432
thousand dollars
and we thought we will be able to
produce many artworks with a higher
quality
and not limit it to selling one piece
for one hundred thousand dollars
sell it to as many people as we can for
for a much more affordable amount like a
hundred dollars
and so so i told her listen if you think
you can do it
sit down why won't you sit down build
the algorithm and if we'll have
something successful we'll open up a
company
we'll open a store and we'll start
presenting it to the world and start
selling that
so after about six months
we had an initial prototype of an
algorithm this is not the algorithm that
we're using today
especially as we're using several
different algorithms today but it was
good enough
to fool people and make them think that
the artwork that we're looking at
were generated by or created by humans
and some of them even thought well that
will be a cool thing that i'm willing to
hang on my wall
so we opened up a store and we started
presenting air generated art to the
public
uh and yourself myself we knew about air
generated out a bit before that we knew
that were like
very very small number of pieces that
were sold before
but most of the people never even heard
about the possibility of creating such
art
and we didn't create one we create
thousands of them
and to date we created tens of thousands
of them and we started presenting it
to people online and they understood the
concept
and they loved the concept and we were
able to
sell a lot of one-of-a-kind pieces of
art
created by artificial intelligence
intelligence to sell it at affordable
prices
and to get to the homes of thousands of
customers all over the world actually
thousands of collectors and here we are
today
so we have to go you know a little bit
high up in the air because we're
what we're talking about here is not
just another product that you're saying
yes we invented another type of you know
of a product that you know we're gonna
see if people enjoy it and then we're
gonna
just scale but there's something a
little bit deeper that's happening here
you're taking
this idea of creativity and you're
putting a computer to the world
and then you're saying we want to allow
people to purchase
art that was created by a computer which
i think brings on this you know a little
bit of an
existential question can computers be
created
what is the essence of creativity is
what is the value of a painting where
the painting was not
drawn by a by a hand of a woman that
very precisely spent tens of thousands
of hours but it was drawn
through an algorithm that spent time
maybe a few minutes running
what is the conceptuality behind all of
that
all of these are amazing questions uh i
do think that we're time limited here
but if you give me three hours i i
promise you that i
that i'm going to answer at least one of
your questions
um but but um
but what i can say is that all of these
questions are extremely fascinating um
some of them are the core of that that
gives the reason of why
we we decided to give this concept
that much attention and build a company
based on it
um what i can tell you is that um these
questions are being asked
by people from all over the world and we
are facing these questions
every single day several times a day and
um some people are even taking it to the
extreme
so one of the goals that we want to that
we want to bring one of the things that
one of the is to bring the discussion
about
machine creativity which is a
fascinating and confusing thing
so you can ask where is the creativity
if you have no soul because the ai has
no soul
or maybe the artist was the person that
created the algorithm
and maybe maybe something completely
different
so my personal opinion on that is of
course we're speaking about real art
and you don't need to have a soul to
create
beautiful designs that make you feel
intense
things intense feelings you definitely
need a soul
right to look at the art and feel and
feel these things that you're feeling
um the fascinating thing about that is
that it is completely unbiased
so when someone a person a human
creates and creates out
doesn't matter how much you try to fight
it you are
biased in at least at least a little
because when you're creating this
artwork you're remembering things that
happened to you in the
in the past or maybe you had a bad day
or a good day before you started
uh um painting the artwork and it
affects how it looks like
with the ai no no such
thoughts are going through its neural
network it
completely depended on the person that
is viewing the artwork
and the interpretation that this
specific person is giving to the artwork
and this is also why it is so important
for each and every one
for us as a company for each and every
one
to choose the artwork that they can
connect to the most and we're not
telling them what happened in this
artwork
or what what this artwork makes us feel
it depends on the people that are
viewing that and we can see on our
facebook page with currently i think
have like about
40 000 people uh and subscribe to it
that they are discussing and that
happens on every single post that we're
up and that we're uploading
on what does it mean for for this
artwork to make people
feel specific things or maybe it goes
against the the nature of art
is it okay to do that is it not okay to
do that
and other than my personal opinion that
it is completely okay to do that
um it is more fascinating for us to see
people from all over the world
discussing that and bringing
fascinating new concept fascinating new
ideas even though i read
probably i don't know 10 000 comments
about this subject
uh and they can probably help you quite
a lot if you're doing a research about
it
to give you very very interesting point
of views still every single day i'm
encountering
um new concepts and new opinions that i
never heard before
about this very interesting combination
between art
and technology i think we touched here
on two very interesting
cases that are important to look at one
is this idea that you know what is the
purpose of art what is the purpose of
creativity
and what you're saying is well at the
core of it the the primary
reason we have artists to invoke
emotions within the viewer
right and now it doesn't really matter
why this
art was created or what happened through
its creation
the mere fact that it invokes these
dramatic emotions
is enough to to satisfy the idea that
yes there is a reason for this to exist
because if the ai didn't do it then this
specific painting would not have existed
otherwise
it just wouldn't it not in the core
sense it is but the other thing that is
i think it's still important as i said
you know i remember going to museums
early on
and you know reading this the reason of
the speculation of why picasso drew
the woman in that shape and why you know
they had a fight with that woman and
then through the divorce etc
that's interesting those things are
interesting that i think that we do have
to forgo
when we're talking about you know ai
that's unbiased because those stories
do also invoke emotions but i am
completely
on the idea that the scale in which ai
can generate art that evokes emotion
that trumps everything that making it
accessible for everybody to have a
beautiful painting in their home
then invokes those emotions and you
don't have to go and buy hundreds of
thousands of dollars
and that i think that's that is really
the democratization that's beautiful
thank you so much and there's one more
additional very cool thing that we can
do
is that we are tuning the algorithm like
every algorithm
every piece of software needs a goal
needs purpose and the purpose of this
algorithm
the way it is tuned is to create
the most engaging the most emotive
pieces of art so we have a machine
that is aimed to create artworks that
will make you
feel emotions as intense as possible
right i think that's amazing so so now
we're in 2021
the world is starting to understand the
power of these things you know
in the same line of work we can put deep
fakes
and uh you know defeat both for audio
and video
and really this questioning of what is
reality and what is the essence of of
reality and does it even matter and so
obviously it matters in some cases but
what i'm curious about is
where are we headed from here where do
you position yourself in this new market
in this new landscape
of of art specifically but how do you
see this market growing what is the
reception you're getting from customers
and where is rdi moving you know
specifically
another great question so for a lot of
people
this um this
concept of a.i becoming a bigger part of
our lives
not not in art in everywhere is a bit
scary
so people thinking about the terminator
and skynet and robots are going to take
over the world
and for many people art was the final
frontier
so you can take everything but out now
that's only for human
and you bring ai into this so we're
going past the final frontal so what's
what's happening right now
and i think that imagining
art human art being replaced without it
is created by machines
that's simply impossible art is out
there
since since you know
humans have been drawn yeah humans have
been drawing on caves
and and that's that's going to stay out
is is there i was about to say hundreds
of years but that's thousands of years
and nothing is going to change yet the
only thing that we can do is we can add
on top same way that in the 80s people
started using a synthesizer to create
new type of music
and then musicians had another tool they
could utilize to create
new music and think about amazing
new creations the people that people
really enjoyed the same thing is
happening without
um for many many years now and another
part of this art evolution
that is adding to art adding like
another generator out but not replacing
it
is ai generated out so this art
will in a way we're looking at it like a
tool and this is why it is very
important for us to work with digital
artists
and we're making several different
projects with digital artists at the
moment and you were asking
what do you think is is going to be the
role of of
ai of art ai on the art market
so one of the one of the roles that
we're that that we're investing right
now is to help digital artists create
new type of art so there is a big
variety
of designs and artworks that we can do
as a brand that creates
its own designs but there's so much more
that we can do if we work together with
artists which are creative by nature
so you know that every time that you're
walking with someone without someone new
it's
something new is going to to become out
of it and i do think that
the same way that a programmer always
needs to be aware of the newest
technologies
uh because they need to be on top of the
newest technologies if they want to
to continue and go forward with their
with their careers
same thing for digital artists they need
to be familiar with the newest
technologies
and right now the newest technology is
air generated out
and using uh smart algorithms and neural
networks
to create new type of creations and the
people that are going to be on top of
that
are going to have a better chance of
succeeding of making it as digital
artists especially as
this is a saturated market so one of the
things that we want to do is we want to
help digital artists
the other thing that we want to do is we
want to explore this world and we know
there is so much to explore because i
said earlier there's not a single day
that passes
that i i'm not encountering a new idea
and a new segment
of this market that we can explore and
just generate really really beautiful
and interesting things
right i think this is um it's it's
magical really we know what's happening
and
and i can only imagine where we're gonna
be in you know 10 15 years
and with the empowerment and i think
that you know one of the things that you
know people
tend to forget quickly is this this
notion of what does it mean to be an
artist
you know is it a person that is that has
a unique ability to have a steady hand
and draw very precisely
or is it a person that has you know
these amazing thoughts and and just
needs to let them out on paper
and i i saw i i read an article about a
i generated music
by an artist a tracy something and she
said i'm not a song i'm a songwriter i
don't know how to write melodies i don't
know how i don't know music theory
but she worked with an ai algorithm that
helped her compose a song and she
released her own song
which is a big hit on youtube now with
millions of views and and
what i'm taking from this i'm saying you
know yeah it's you know great when
you're doing
beautiful art you're letting people buy
it and hang on the walls that's amazing
what i really get excited about is the
fact that every single person
can potentially be can become an artist
even if they don't know how to hold a
paintbrush
potentially me talking or communicating
with the ai in some capacity
and expressing my thoughts and letting
the and letting that
that actual mechanical work be done for
me that can bring a whole new generation
of artists
that are just don't exist today
i completely agree and and that's that's
amazing and i can tell you more than
that that if you go to our website and
you're browsing out walks
without even paying attention you're
already taking part in the creation of
future artworks
because there is an endless loop that
takes to count
the the engagement with our existing art
if you like an
artwork if you of course purchase an
artwork if you just look at the artwork
long enough we take this information and
using this information
we know which artworks are better suited
to
to invoke emotions and the future
algorithms are trained
based on this input so we could create
the new generation of outlook that
is taking the input of everyone that
visit our gallery
and that's another thing that you cannot
do as a human artist
you can ask your friends or or your fans
what do you think about this artwork
what should i do next but you can't
take the input and the sentiment of
thousands of people
and use all of this input to create new
art so
in a way it's it's it is created by
artificial intelligence but
it requires the input of so many human
beings
for it for it to even exist ben
and i i love the work i'm gonna be
spending hours now
on the on the website and i'm gonna have
to talk a little bit more about
about the about the the research i'm
doing and but but thank you for
you know for it it's you know creating
this whole new market that we still
don't understand what it means i you
know i think that
you know the vast majority of people in
the world both don't know that it's
possible
but even those that do know that it's
possible we don't yet fathom that this
is our new reality this is the new world
that's in front of us
and and and i'm just i'm personally very
excited by this new world
and i very much hope that the vast
majority of the population will be too
and then thank you for coming to the
show i really really appreciate it
and the last question the hardest one
that after it was a pleasure
thank you is three words you would use
to describe yourself
oh man um okay
so i would say that
i am i am keen
it is hard for me to skip information
that i find intriguing and i find too
many things
too intriguing um
i would say that i'm
i would say that i'm quick and i will
i will assign this i will thank this
this attribute
thanks to my to my add um
so i just have to do things very very
quickly and unless i i lose focus
uh and quite absurdly i will also say
focused so um kind of kind of opposite
opposite there but i find the thing that
i find really really intriguing and then
i'm completely focused on them
being quick and focused ben thank you
very much
best of luck and i can't wait to see
both the online and physical galleries
and
and explore this new world of art thank
you
thank you so much it was a pleasure